Shure: 他咋跳着呀哈哈哈
Shure: How is he dancing? Hahaha.
Shure: 6
Shure: Six.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:什么鬼
Alice: What the heck.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 嘿呀他妈的
Shure: Hey, damn it.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 跨肩膀肩膀跨
Shure: Cross shoulders, shoulders cross.
Shure: 这几个关节好像2哒3哒45678 哇
Shure: These joints seem like two da three da four five six seven eight. Wow.
Shure: 还扎马步
Shure: Still doing horse stance.
Shure: 哇
Shure: Wow.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Shure: 张元英转圈是吧
Shure: Zhang Yuanying is spinning, right?
Shure: 不行这真不会啊
Shure: No, I really can't do this.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Shure: 7
Tasha: 斯哈难度不对吧
Tasha: Is the difficulty of the Saha move correct?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Shure: 这是0.5倍速是吗
Shure: Is this at 0.5x speed?
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure: 不行了不行了今天到点为止吧哈哈
Shure: I can't do it anymore, let's call it a day haha
Tasha: 呵啊呵啊呵嗯呵嗯
Tasha: Ha ah ha ah hmm ha hmm
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:再来一次再来一次
Jake: One more time, one more time
Katrina: 把前两部分回顾一下
Katrina: Let's review the first two parts
Jake:我们
Jake: We
Choiszt: 我们要放前两个
Choiszt: We need to do the first two
Shure: 脑容量要炸了
Shure: My brain is about to explode
Katrina: 手机呢调往前调一下
Katrina: Where's the phone? Adjust it to the beginning
Jake:放哪了
Jake: Where did you put it?
Katrina: 你是要录我们刚刚跟音乐的吗
Katrina: Are you going to record us with the music we just played?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Katrina: 还是从头
Katrina: Or from the start?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh
Jake:就是你们来跳一次比较完整的就行
Jake: Just do a complete run-through
Shure: 那我们给大家展示一下这个第一部分
Shure: Let's show everyone the first part
Shure: 我们跳的最好的这一部分吧
Shure: The part we did the best
Jake:全景相机
Jake: Panoramic camera
Jake:就是相当于这边处一人看你们
Jake: So it's like someone over here will be watching you
Shure: OK准备好了吗
Shure: OK, ready?
Shure: ready
Shure: Ready
Jake:是你王德
Jake: It's you, Wang De
Katrina: 嗯哼
Katrina: Mhm
Shure: 二三四五六七八
Shure: Two three four five six seven eight
Shure: 二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two two three four five six seven eight
Shure: 三二三四五六七八
Shure: Three two three four five six seven eight
Shure: 四二三四好二三起
Shure: Four two three four, okay, two three start
Shure: 一二三四张二收
Shure: One two three four spread two hold
Shure: 二三二三四摆来二三滑
Shure: Two three two three four sway two three slide
Shure: 二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two two three four five six seven eight
Tasha: 噗呵呵
Tasha: Pfff haha
Shure: 伸二比心张
Shure: Stretch two make a heart open
Shure: 二三走一二
Shure: Two three walk one two
Shure: 二三四五六七八
Shure: Two three four five six seven eight
Shure: 一二三四五六七八
Shure: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight
Shure: 踏步二一二三四
Shure: March, two, one, two, three, four
Shure: 一二三四跑
Shure: One, two, three, four, run
Shure: 跳二三四
Shure: Jump, two, three, four
Shure: 张二收二三四划二三四
Shure: Open, two, close, two, three, four, stroke, two, three, four
Shure: 摸手二三四顶二三四
Shure: Touch hands, two, three, four, push, two, three, four
Shure: 二三四一二三停
Shure: Two, three, four, one, two, three, stop
Shure: 简单
Shure: Simple
Katrina: 第二部分要不要再过一遍
Katrina: Should we go over the second part again?
Shure: 来第二部分
Shure: Let's do the second part
Shure: 再跟他过一遍直接0.75
Shure: Go over it again at 0.75 speed
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Jake:真0.75
Jake: Yeah, really at 0.75
Shure: 我觉得我们可以直接第一和第二连起来
Shure: I think we can connect the first and second parts directly
Katrina: 哇你就这么自信的吗
Katrina: Wow, are you that confident?
Jake:这是
Jake: This is
Choiszt: 这个算不算完整的
Choiszt: Does this count as a complete one?
Nicous: 不你以为这三个拍
Nicous: No, you think these three parts
Nicous: 我觉得是
Nicous: I think it does
Lucia: 这三部分加起来
Lucia: These three parts combined
Lucia: 好像没有到完整的时长
Lucia: It doesn't seem to be the full length
Katrina: 那就从头单曲循环
Katrina: Then let's loop it from the beginning
Shure: 一二三四二二三四一二甩
Shure: One, two, three, four, two, two, three, four, one, two, swing
Shure: 二张二开二一二三四
Shure: Two, open, two, spread, two, one, two, three, four
Shure: 41234223412
Shure: Four, one, two, three, four, two, three, four, one, two
Shure: 最够一二三四五六七八
Shure: Finally, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight
Shure: 二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight
Shure: 转胯三四五六拍拍
Shure: Swivel hips, three, four, five, six, clap
Shure: 一二三四五六七停
Shure: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, stop
Lucia: 我觉得第二趴还是练一下吧
Lucia: I think we should practice the second part more
Lucia: 因为手和脚上动作要合一下
Lucia: Because we need to coordinate the hand and foot movements
Choiszt: 啊哈
Choiszt: Aha
Nicous: 不行
Nicous: No way
Jake:好好下一个环节
Jake: Alright, next segment
Choiszt: 嗯哈哈
Choiszt: Mm-hmm, haha
Katrina: 下一个环节
Katrina: Next segment
Jake:记得花
Jake: Remember the flower
Katrina: 哦哦哦你说行行
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh, you mean, okay, okay
Shure: 哦结束了是吧
Shure: Oh, it's over, right?
Jake:行吧好好好行
Jake: Alright then, okay, okay, okay, fine
Choiszt: 他们已经录了一遍小时
Choiszt: They've already recorded an hour.
Shure: 这是谁啊
Shure: Who's this?
Shure: 哎欠一呀呀呀呀呀呀呀
Shure: Ah, achoo!
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Jake:都录着了
Jake: It's all recorded.
Jake:啊哈哈好
Jake: Ah, okay.
Katrina: 行吧去选花吧
Katrina: Alright, let's go pick some flowers.
Shure: 他的出镜率不比他来的出镜率低是吧
Shure: His screen time isn't less than his arrival time, right?
Jake:对我们第第7位选手
Jake: Yes, our seventh contestant.
Katrina: 几点钟了
Katrina: What time is it?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Katrina: 哦 4点了
Katrina: Oh, it's 4 o'clock.
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, it is.
Katrina: 那就选一下花
Katrina: Then let's pick some flowers.
Jake:对拧个花就是我们的活动
Jake: Yes, picking flowers is our activity.
Jake:我们可以再给你跟跟剧组讲解一下的
Jake: We can explain it to the crew again.
Nicous: 挑了一些花
Nicous: Pick some flowers.
Choiszt: 插花做的做的干花
Choiszt: Make some floral arrangements, dried flowers.
Jake:也不是就是可能是7天
Jake: Or maybe it lasts for about 7 days.
Tasha: 哈啊啊
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice:你会跳
Alice: Can you dance?
Tasha: 没学会
Tasha: Haven't learned.
Jake:走吧下去吧
Jake: Let's go downstairs.
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia: 反正真的记住他要记挺长一阵子
Lucia: Anyway, if you remember him, it will be for a long time.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:得一直处于摄像头上
Jake: Got to stay in front of the camera.
Jake:那不行没有的话
Jake: Otherwise, it won't work.
Tasha: （歌词）用心去回应你给的真心
Tasha: (lyrics) Respond to you with sincerity.
Tasha: all reght
Tasha: Alright.
Lucia: 但是理论上说
Lucia: But theoretically,
Lucia: 最后跳怎样其实不是特别重要
Lucia: how you dance in the end isn't that important.
Lucia: 对吧我们只要有这个数据
Lucia: Right, as long as we have the data.
Katrina: 写一下名字簿
Katrina: Write down the name.
Katrina: 然后贴挑一束花
Katrina: Then pick a bunch of flowers.
Katrina: 然后每天要给他拍照
Katrina: And take photos every day.
Nicous: 这么牛逼的
Nicous: That's awesome.
Katrina: 对因为有了花苞
Katrina: Yeah, because there are flower buds.
Katrina: 这就是他会慢慢盛开
Katrina: So it will slowly bloom.
Nicous: 这是什么人的想法
Nicous: Whose idea is this?
Shure: 这个创建一下
Shure: Let's create this.
Katrina: 写名字写名字贴
Katrina: Write the name, write the name tag.
Shure: 写名字
Shure: Write the name.
Jake:写名字写呗
Jake: Write the name, just write it.
Shure: 谁让你跳的呵呵呵
Shure: Who told you to dance, haha.
Katrina: 偷偷挑的
Katrina: Secretly picked.
Katrina: 挑是最好的
Katrina: Picking is the best.
Katrina: 今晚上还可以再练
Katrina: We can practice again tonight.
Jake:哎你你俩有
Jake: Hey, you two have...
Jake:有你俩事
Jake: You two have something.
Jake:你俩在打
Jake: You two are fighting.
Jake:我出去来
Jake: I'm going out.
Katrina: 我的草莓种
Katrina: My strawberry seeds.
Jake:到位了啊兄弟们到位了
Jake: All set, guys, all set.
Tasha: 嗯哦
Tasha: Hmm, oh.
Tasha: 这有人了
Tasha: Someone's here.
Tasha: 名花有主了
Tasha: The flower has an owner now.
Tasha: 那就你吧
Tasha: Then it's you.
Katrina: 我这个好，反正他离我是近的
Katrina: This one's good, it's close to me anyway.
Katrina: 这是要泡几分钟
Katrina: This needs to soak for a few minutes.
Alice:这个好像没有勺药
Alice: This one seems to have no peony medicine.
Lucia: 有他应该是还没开
Lucia: There is, it just hasn't opened yet.
Lucia: 就是应该各种就里面都都放了
Lucia: It should be inside, all put inside.
Katrina: 都都放了芍药的球球
Katrina: All put peony balls inside.
Katrina: 等它慢慢开就行
Katrina: Just wait for it to bloom slowly.
Katrina: 对这些都是芍药球
Katrina: Yes, these are all peony balls.
Katrina: 芍药开出
Katrina: Peonies bloom.
Lucia: 啊我可以写了哎
Lucia: Ah, I can write now, hey.
Katrina: 出来出来出来
Katrina: Come out, come out, come out.
Katrina: 自己房间装饰是吧
Katrina: Decorating your own room, right?
Lucia: 可以把它融入到我们的房间装饰里
Lucia: We can incorporate it into our room decoration.
Katrina: 你也可以把它放在这客厅某一个位置
Katrina: You can also put it in a spot in the living room.
Katrina: 都行反正你自己管着
Katrina: Whatever, it's up to you.
Katrina: 他每天要拍照
Katrina: It needs to be photographed every day.
Shure: 他每天要拍照
Shure: It needs to be photographed every day.
Katrina: 哎呀老学我的口音干什么
Katrina: Oh, why are you imitating my accent?
Katrina: 哈哈哈可以放外面播
Katrina: Haha, you can put it outside to broadcast.
Katrina: 他需要那个光合作用吗
Katrina: Does he need photosynthesis?
Katrina: 就是生物钟
Katrina: It's like a biological clock.
Katrina: 他们是需要进行光合作用好像
Katrina: They need to do photosynthesis, I think.
Katrina: 但是也不能长时间进行光合作用
Katrina: But they can't do photosynthesis for too long.
Katrina: 你还记得吗
Katrina: Do you remember?
Shure: 这个内个等等等等
Shure: This, that, and so on...
Katrina: 好像会那个什么死掉
Katrina: It might die if it happens.
Katrina: 就是那个气口
Katrina: It's the stoma.
Shure: 蒸腾作用过的
Shure: Because of transpiration.
Katrina: 对对真疼
Katrina: Yes, yes, transpiration.
Lucia: 灯也是可以的吗
Lucia: Can lights work too?
Shure: 你看看这脑子
Shure: Look at this brain.
Katrina: 就是有文化
Katrina: So knowledgeable.
Tasha: 嗯这怎么断了一根
Tasha: Hmm, why is one branch broken?
Shure: Dyson i need a corporation
Shure: Dyson, I need a corporation.
Jake:哪去了
Jake: Where did it go?
Shure: 这个放哪呢
Shure: Where should I put this?
Shure: 我那面是阴面不宜养花
Shure: My side is shady, not suitable for growing flowers.
Lucia: 放哪呢
Lucia: Where should I put it?
Lucia: 我觉得我房间要放阳台上
Lucia: I think I should put it on the balcony in my room.
Lucia: 挺容易掉下来的
Lucia: It's quite easy to fall off.
Lucia: 因为我那阳台它并不大
Lucia: Because my balcony isn't very big.
Jake:呃等下找不着了
Jake: Uh, wait, I can't find it.
Jake:敲完了吗大伙
Jake: Is everyone done?
Alice:你贴了吗
Alice: Did you stick it?
Shure: 对啊我也觉得
Shure: Yeah, I think so too.
Jake:你拿下来了
Jake: Did you take it off?
Alice:这个是你的吗
Alice: Is this yours?
Tasha: 最里面那个嗯哼
Tasha: The innermost one, uh-huh.
Katrina: 还有球球吗
Katrina: Are there any balls left?
Lucia: 今天的照片我把它放哪拍呢
Lucia: Where should I take today's photos?
Tasha: 嗯哼
Tasha: Uh-huh.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 看看芍药需要几天才能开花
Katrina: Let's see how many days it takes for the peonies to bloom.
Lucia: 这里
Lucia: Here.
Jake:yes
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 幸亏他妈的奶可乐
Shure: Thank God for the milk cola.
Alice:让我给他修剪一下
Alice: Let me trim it a bit.
Lucia: 有一点点背光
Lucia: It's a bit backlit.
Jake:挑好了吗
Jake: Have you picked it?
Katrina: 调好了吗调好了
Katrina: Is it adjusted? It's adjusted.
Alice:这个是可以剪花的
Alice: This can be used to cut flowers.
Jake:给我留的哪个呀
Jake: Which one is left for me?
Tasha: 那要不拿昨天那个剪
Tasha: How about we use the one from yesterday?
Katrina: 是不是最里面那个这个这
Katrina: Is it the innermost one, this one?
Alice:昨天那个在哪
Alice: Where is the one from yesterday?
Jake:这个
Jake: This one.
Jake:这什么花呀
Jake: What flower is this?
Katrina: 这是芍药
Katrina: This is a peony.
Katrina: 这应该也是芍药
Katrina: This should also be a peony.
Katrina: 这是康乃馨
Katrina: This is a carnation.
Katrina: 然后这是百合
Katrina: And this is a lily.
Alice:哎剪子在哪里
Alice: Hey, where are the scissors?
Katrina: 就买了这几种
Katrina: I only bought these kinds.
Tasha: 在这呢
Tasha: They're here.
Alice:剪花的那个
Alice: The flower-cutting ones.
Shure: 我给自己的花起个名吧
Shure: I'll give my flower a name.
Katrina: sunshine
Katrina: Sunshine.
Alice:你可以叫sunshine或者叫smile
Alice: You can call it Sunshine or Smile.
Shure: smart可还行
Shure: How about Smart?
Jake:这个不能乱关
Jake: You can't just turn this off.
Jake:所以关了硬盘就会好
Jake: So, turning off the hard drive will fix it.
Jake:然后搞成这个样子
Jake: And then it ends up like this.
Shure: 血汗工厂开店
Shure: The sweatshop is open.
Nicous: 开店
Nicous: It's open.
Nicous: 关键坐这儿
Nicous: The key is to sit here.
Nicous: 卧槽
Nicous: Whoa.
Choiszt: 我这只能贴这两样
Choiszt: I can only stick these two.
Jake:你你们进去吧
Jake: You guys go inside.
Jake:这这两个给你们
Jake: These two are for you.
Katrina: 哇好像那是自习室啊
Katrina: Wow, it looks like a study room.
Jake:这
Jake: This.
Katrina: 就是那补习班
Katrina: It's like a tutoring center.
Katrina: 然后现在推门进去减负
Katrina: And now we open the door to reduce the load.
Lucia: 哈哈对
Lucia: Haha, right.
Jake:血汗工厂
Jake: Sweatshop.
Katrina: 不准办补习班
Katrina: No tutoring centers allowed.
Lucia: 不可办公
Lucia: No offices allowed.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:不准办公
Jake: No offices allowed.
Jake:禁止办公
Jake: No working allowed.
Jake:这边贴一个禁止办公
Jake: Let's put up a "no working" sign here.
Lucia: 这标这标语我喜欢
Lucia: I like this slogan.
Katrina: 拍拍坐像那种
Katrina: Just take a seat and pose.
Shure: 你们你们仨是网吧
Shure: Are you three in an internet cafe?
Shure: 3连坐是吗
Shure: Sitting in a row?
Katrina: 哈哈哈真的像
Katrina: Haha, it really looks like it.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 这外面这桌子是不是有点有点歪
Lucia: Is this table outside a bit crooked?
Lucia: 这个板
Lucia: This board.
Lucia: 不是就是这板好像不太平
Lucia: It seems like this board isn't very flat.
Jake:对对对是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes, it is.
Lucia: 对对对是平时不够哦OK
Lucia: Yeah, it's not flat enough. Oh, OK.
Jake:他就是不够
Jake: It's just not enough.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:不过也行这样就好
Jake: But it's fine, this is good enough.
Shure: 我天啊
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure: 你们仨准备打点什么
Shure: What are you three planning to play?
Shure: 英雄联盟吗
Shure: League of Legends?
Jake:三个人能打什么呀
Jake: What can three people play?
Jake:帮我拿一下
Jake: Give me a hand.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Alice:斗地主
Alice: Fight the Landlord.
Lucia: 三个人
Lucia: Three people.
Jake:帮我拿一下
Jake: Give me a hand.
Shure: 三个人APEX
Shure: Three people can play Apex.
Lucia: 三个人可以
Lucia: Three people can.
Lucia: 三个人可以联机玩刺客信条黑棋
Lucia: Three people can play Assassin's Creed Black Flag online.
Shure: 可以永结无间
Shure: Or play Naraka.
Jake:好好好行了行了
Jake: Okay, okay, that's enough.
Shure: 这时候赶紧给我们的网易打个广告
Shure: It's time to quickly advertise for our NetEase.
Jake:这样好
Jake: This is good.
Shure: 这是干嘛的呀
Shure: What's this for?
Lucia: 做引体向上的哈哈哈
Lucia: For doing pull-ups, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Shure: 挂个杆然后做引体向上是吗
Shure: Hang a bar and do pull-ups, right?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Jake:行行行挺好挺好
Jake: Alright, alright, that's good.
Shure: 能能成功吗
Shure: Will it work?
Jake:挺好挺好挺好挺好
Jake: It's good, it's good, it's good.
Lucia: 我们乱说的
Lucia: We were just talking nonsense.
Lucia: 小心一点
Lucia: Be careful.
Shure: 主要我撑不起来
Shure: Mainly, I can't hold it up.
Shure: 需要给他修剪吗
Shure: Do we need to trim it?
Katrina: 随便你你的话
Katrina: It's up to you.
Lucia: 你想修的话可以修呀
Lucia: If you want to trim it, go ahead.
Jake:也不用那么高
Jake: It doesn't need to be that high.
Shure: 我不修因为我姓
Shure: I won't trim because my last name is...
Jake:就你就卡到这就行
Jake: Just cut it to here, it's fine.
Shure: 修了一下
Shure: Trimmed it a bit.
Lucia: 哦哦
Lucia: Oh, oh.
Alice:不缺修
Alice: No need to trim it.
Jake:高了我怕他摔
Jake: If it's too high, I'm afraid he'll fall.
Jake:你看这个就是我的床的入口
Jake: Look, this is the entrance to my bed.
Lucia: 为什么这几个球球到现在还没有开
Lucia: Why haven't these balls opened yet?
Jake:全自动全自动入口你说
Jake: Fully automatic, fully automatic entrance, you know.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 你能过来吗
Shure: Can you come over?
Jake:哈哈哈能啊这个一跳我就上上床
Jake: Hahaha, yes, with one jump, I can get on the bed.
Shure: 这么大地
Shure: It's so big.
Jake:对上床入口
Jake: Yeah, it's the entrance to the bed.
Shure: 我靠哎呦喂
Shure: Damn, wow.
Lucia: sorry一跳就上涨了可爱笑
Lucia: Sorry, with one jump, it's up, so cute and funny.
Jake:对哈哈对对对入口
Jake: Yes, haha, yes, yes, the entrance.
Katrina: 嗯理想中的房间
Katrina: Hmm, the ideal room.
Katrina: 哈哈哈学习完倒头就睡
Katrina: Hahaha, after studying, you just lie down and sleep.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Jake:饶了我吧哈哈哈
Jake: Spare me, hahaha.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This...
Lucia: 这个确实是软件工程李小忠的房间了
Lucia: This is indeed Li Xiaozhong's software engineering room.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 对写完代码直接倒头就睡
Katrina: Yeah, you finish coding and then just lie down and sleep.
Jake:哎盘呢
Jake: Hey, where's the plate?
Lucia: 啊哪哪个
Lucia: Huh, which one?
Jake:哦哦哦对对对刚刚对刚刚
Jake: Oh, right, right, the one just now.
Lucia: 刚拿过来的这个吗
Lucia: The one we just brought over?
Katrina: 哎二楼这投影仪也可以
Katrina: Hey, the projector on the second floor is nice too.
Katrina: 那款放点music可以吗
Katrina: Can we play some music on that one?
Jake:对易老也是
Jake: Yes, Yilao also...
Shure: 来电music
Shure: Incoming music
Katrina: yes反正戴了眼镜了
Katrina: Yes, anyway, I'm wearing glasses now.
Jake:来点music
Jake: Play some music.
Katrina: 已经录下来
Katrina: It's already recording.
Jake:你们你们要现在是要干啥呀按照
Jake: So, what are you guys planning to do now?
Katrina: 我们可以讨论一下
Katrina: We can discuss it.
Katrina: 我们的那个房间装饰
Katrina: Our room decoration.
Katrina: 你不说要录录录下来吗
Katrina: Didn't you say you wanted to record it?
Jake:对对然后这个他们应该
Jake: Yes, yes, and they should be...
Jake:他说是4五点会有人过来收拾
Jake: He said someone would come to clean up around 4 or 5.
Jake:对然后那会收拾
Jake: Yeah, and then they'll clean up.
Jake:收拾完我们就扫房间
Jake: After they clean up, we'll sweep the room.
Jake:就是扫3D扫
Jake: I mean, sweep it in 3D.
Jake:嗯对我靠
Jake: Hmm, yeah, wow.
Jake:4399 呵呵呵
Jake: 4399, hahaha.
Katrina: 那几点准备食材呢
Katrina: So when do we prepare the ingredients?
Jake:呃对那要不现在就开始准备食材吧
Jake: Uh, yeah, let's start preparing the ingredients now.
Shure: 死神vs火影
Shure: Bleach vs Naruto.
Shure: 这不得来一把
Shure: We have to play a game.
Jake:然后
Jake: And then...
Jake:对现在开始准备食材
Jake: Yes, start preparing the ingredients now.
Jake:就现在就看一看
Jake: Just take a look now.
Jake:准备准备
Jake: Start preparing.
Katrina: 现在也可以看那个房间装饰购买
Katrina: Now we can also look at room decoration purchases.
Jake:也可以
Jake: We can do that too.
Katrina: 然后5点他来收拾然后扫房间
Katrina: Then at 5, they'll come to clean, and we'll sweep the room.
Katrina: 我们只需要稍微
Katrina: We just need to...
Tasha: 把我的也修一下吧
Tasha: Fix mine too.
Katrina: 收拾一下我们就下来忙这个呗
Katrina: Clean up a bit, then get busy with this.
Katrina: 对扫房间
Katrina: Yes, sweep the room.
Katrina: 扫房间是你们三个弄是吧
Katrina: You three are in charge of sweeping, right?
Tasha: 嘿
Tasha: Hey.
Jake:呃这打扫房间是不是
Jake: Uh, is sweeping the room...
Tasha:我把我的房间
Tasha: I'll take care of my room.
Tasha: 垃圾全部都放到我的行李箱
Tasha: Put all the trash in my suitcase.
Jake:嗯不用不用
Jake: Hmm, no need, no need.
Jake:我们都不用弄
Jake: We don't need to do it.
Katrina: OK那我们那个吧
Katrina: OK, then let's...
Tasha: 是那你先放也行
Tasha: It's fine if you put it there first.
Katrina: 我看我要买什么
Katrina: I'll see what I need to buy.
Jake:OK来关掉4399
Jake: OK, let's close 4399.
Tasha: allrightallright
Tasha: alright, alright
Tasha: allright
Tasha: alright
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Tasha: 怎么办呢
Tasha: What should we do?
Tasha: 这衣服该放在哪里呢
Tasha: Where should we put these clothes?
Tasha: what's this
Tasha: What's this?
Tasha: 好吧咖啡哈
Tasha: Okay, coffee, huh?
Tasha: 嗯好像也没有很乱
Tasha: Hmm, it doesn't seem that messy.
Tasha: 这两个是退的
Tasha: These two are returns.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Tasha: 呲嗯
Tasha: Pss, hmm
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Eh
Tasha: 全部一股脑塞进来吧
Tasha: Let's just stuff everything in here.
Tasha: 就这样
Tasha: Just like that.
Tasha: 就这样被你
Tasha: Just like that, by you.
Tasha: 嗯嗯嗯
Tasha: Hmm, hmm, hmm
Tasha: 这是用来干什么的
Tasha: What's this for?
Tasha: 哎就放这吧
Tasha: Eh, just put it here.
Tasha: 哼
Tasha: Hmph
Tasha: 斯（歌词）你的目光为我撑腰我最后
Tasha: (lyrics) Your gaze supports me, my last...
Tasha: 嘿
Tasha: Hey
Tasha: 脏袜子
Tasha: Dirty socks.
Tasha: 偷偷藏在哪里呢
Tasha: Where should I secretly hide them?
Tasha: 嗯手机没啊
Tasha: Hmm, no phone?
Tasha: 今天晚上就洗
Tasha: I'll wash them tonight.
Tasha: 屏幕前的你们不要担心
Tasha: To everyone watching, don't worry.
Tasha: 好吧我今天晚上就洗
Tasha: Okay, I'll wash them tonight.
Tasha: 嘿
Tasha: Hey
Tasha: 之前不是懒
Tasha: I wasn't lazy before,
Tasha: 是忙太忙了
Tasha: just too busy.
Tasha: 疏忽了OK
Tasha: I neglected it, okay.
Tasha: please believe me
Tasha: Please believe me.
Tasha: 噜噜噜噜噜
Tasha: Lulululu
Tasha: 这是我需要带下去的
Tasha: I need to take this downstairs.
Tasha: 这是我的化妆包
Tasha: This is my makeup bag.
Tasha: 这是我今天的实物灯
Tasha: This is my desk lamp for today.
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This
Tasha: 就这样吧
Tasha: Just like this.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Tasha: 好就这样吧
Tasha: Okay, let's do it this way.
Choiszt: 等一下我直接吧内个就是
Choiszt: Wait a second, I'll just...
Jake:好这样这个这个是1111是空的
Jake: Alright, this one, this one, 1111 is empty.
Tasha: 嗯拍照去了
Tasha: Hmm, taking a photo.
Jake:不管他然后你你这边手上是什么
Jake: Never mind that, what's in your hand?
Lucia: 那我点那个滚石的
Lucia: Then I'll pick that Rolling Stones one.
Lucia: 不是滚石枪花的希文沃
Lucia: No, the Guns N' Roses' "Civil War."
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Lucia: 哈哈超喜欢这个
Lucia: Haha, I love this one.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oops.
Jake:还没有一张还没有
Jake: Not a single one yet.
Lucia: 突然想起来
Lucia: Just remembered.
Jake:行这样吧
Jake: Alright, let's do it like this.
Jake:就是你这二楼的
Jake: You, on the second floor.
Shure: 这才是老摇滚
Shure: This is real rock and roll.
Jake:呃视频主搞一楼的好吧
Jake: Uh, the main video is done on the first floor, okay?
Katrina: 经常在听
Katrina: I listen often.
Jake:你你不用
Jake: You don't need to.
Katrina: 老歌好有意思
Katrina: Old songs are so interesting.
Jake:就是首先你下一个下一个
Jake: First of all, you, next one, next one.
Katrina: 大家的风格都完全不一样
Katrina: Everyone's style is completely different.
Jake:VLC VLC VLC VLC啊
Jake: VLC, VLC, VLC, VLC.
Shure: 谁刚刚没有点歌来着要点歌
Shure: Who hasn't picked a song yet? Pick a song.
Lucia: 微微点歌吗
Lucia: Did Vivi pick a song?
Katrina: 他点了蝴蝶
Katrina: She picked "Butterfly."
Tasha: 我吗
Tasha: Me?
Katrina: 哦那个我也点过
Katrina: Oh, I picked that one too.
Shure: 蝴蝶点过了
Shure: "Butterfly" was picked already.
Lucia: 嗯对
Lucia: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 你还你还你
Lucia: You, you, you.
Lucia: 还没点应该
Lucia: Haven't picked a song yet.
Shure: 还有谁没点
Shure: Who else hasn't picked?
Katrina: 有啥想听得歌不
Katrina: Any songs you want to hear?
Tasha: 路亚要点一首是吗
Tasha: Is Luya going to pick a song?
Lucia: 对也可以多点
Lucia: Yeah, you can pick more.
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:这边要点陈奕迅
Jake: Someone wants to pick Eason Chan.
Lucia: 两首可以点哪个浮夸
Lucia: You can pick two, like "Exaggeration."
Shure: 来首陈奕迅的
Shure: Let's pick an Eason Chan song.
Tasha: 我手机呢
Tasha: Where's my phone?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Shure: 周杰伦没有我是
Shure: Jay Chou doesn't have me
Katrina: 周杰伦没有哦
Katrina: Jay Chou doesn't have it
Lucia: 陈奕迅和周杰伦
Lucia: Eason Chan and Jay Chou
Katrina: 我想听那个爱是一本书
Katrina: I want to listen to that "Love is a Book" song
Tasha: 我又没拿我手机
Tasha: I didn't take my phone
Katrina: 就是陈奕迅的爱是一本书
Katrina: It's Eason Chan's "Love is a Book"
Lucia: 就是陈奕迅的
Lucia: Yeah, it's Eason Chan's
Lucia: 爱吃榴莲
Lucia: Love to eat durian
Shure: 是一本书OK
Shure: It's "Love is a Book," okay
Lucia: 我也来帮陈奕迅点一个
Lucia: I'll also request an Eason Chan song
Tasha: where's my phone
Tasha: Where's my phone
Tasha: okay do you know
Tasha: Okay, do you know
Tasha: do you know where is my phone
Tasha: Do you know where my phone is
Lucia: 谁的有谁的电话吗这是
Lucia: Whose phone is this
Tasha: 啊我手机居然在这里
Tasha: Ah, my phone is actually here
Jake:哈哈哈你从你从9号开始
Jake: Haha, you started from the 9th
Jake:8号在一楼
Jake: The 8th is on the first floor
Jake:呃9号
Jake: Uh, the 9th
Jake:对十一号跳过去
Jake: Yes, skip to the 11th
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes
Jake:然后你们要做的事情是把每一层
Jake: Then what you need to do is, for each floor
Jake:就是按楼层
Jake: Just by floor
Jake:这个是一楼
Jake: This is the first floor
Katrina: 哇对味
Katrina: Wow, it smells right
Jake:哎这是一楼
Jake: Hey, this is the first floor
Jake:这是二楼
Jake: This is the second floor
Katrina: 爽啦
Katrina: Awesome
Jake:然后我标一下
Jake: Then I'll mark it
Jake:给我一个那个纸
Jake: Give me that paper
Jake:便签纸便签纸都行
Jake: A sticky note, any sticky note will do
Jake:还能是谁哈哈
Jake: Who else could it be haha
Jake:对啊郝哲
Jake: Yeah, Hao Zhe
Katrina: 哎呀怎么把我网名念出来了
Katrina: Hey, why did you say my online name
Jake:呵为什么还在3月2号
Jake: Haha, why is it still March 2nd
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh no
Lucia: 太激动了不想改
Lucia: Too excited, don't want to change it
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes
Jake:等到明年3月2号是吧
Jake: Wait until next March 2nd, right
Katrina: 等到什么时候再看下一场了再改
Katrina: Wait until when, then change for the next event
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Katrina: 对我看第一场
Katrina: Yes, I watched the first show
Katrina: 在武汉我抢到了前驱票
Katrina: In Wuhan, I got the pre-sale tickets
Katrina: 3月2号 哦
Katrina: March 2nd, oh
Tasha: 哈啊
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: sorry哈哈哈
Lucia: Sorry hahaha
Jake:那就整整火锅呗
Jake: Then let's have hotpot
Jake:然后聊一聊你们
Jake: And chat with you all
Katrina: 了OK
Katrina: OK
Katrina: 我要买一下我的东西
Katrina: I need to buy my stuff
Jake:好让数据丰富起来
Jake: Sure, let's get more data
Katrina: 今天可丰富了
Katrina: It's really rich today
Katrina: 今天还那么多肢体动作
Katrina: And there's so much body language today
Jake:确实对现在也要丰富起来
Jake: Indeed, now let's enrich it
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yes, yes
Alice:给你剪
Alice: I'll cut for you
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm
Katrina: 哎我靠真好看
Katrina: Hey, wow, it looks so good
Lucia: 到现在还没想好买啥
Lucia: I still haven't decided what to buy
Katrina: 其实现在好多那种
Katrina: Actually, there are many
Katrina: 就是那种很有意思的做的家居品牌
Katrina: Very interesting home brands now
Lucia: 我选一个整屋定制哈哈哈
Lucia: I chose a whole house customization hahaha
Katrina: 整屋定制
Katrina: Whole house customization
Katrina: 好好看哈哈
Katrina: It looks so good haha
Katrina: 整屋定制
Katrina: Whole house customization
Katrina: 你让杨老板给你报销
Katrina: Ask Jake to reimburse you
Jake:外包是吧
Jake: Outsourcing, right?
Lucia: 对对对哈哈
Lucia: Yes, yes, haha
Jake:外包呵呵
Jake: Outsourcing, haha
Katrina: 整屋定制
Katrina: Whole house customization
Jake:500块钱 200外包
Jake: 500 yuan, 200 outsourcing
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:不是不是VLC啊
Jake: Not VLC
Lucia: 因为这种对于我这个选择恐惧症来说
Lucia: For someone with choice anxiety like me
Lucia: 真的很难搞
Lucia: It's really hard to handle
Katrina: 我还有一个小阳台
Katrina: I also have a small balcony
Katrina: 我阳台上可以放东西
Katrina: I can put things on my balcony
Tasha: 嗯哼
Tasha: Mm-hmm
Tasha: 减无可减
Tasha: Nothing more to cut
Jake:然后但是这个硬盘你你不能摔着
Jake: But you can't drop this hard drive.
Katrina: 他们在工作
Katrina: They're working.
Katrina: 然后这边在放歌
Katrina: And they're playing music here.
Katrina: 这边在剪花
Katrina: And here they're cutting flowers.
Shure: 我给你们加油打气
Shure: I'll cheer you guys on.
Shure: 我给你们跳yes okay
Shure: I'll dance "yes okay" for you.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哎
Lucia: Hahaha hey
Lucia: 我觉得他动作已经很得精髓了
Lucia: I think he's really got the essence of it.
Jake:要不把碗洗了哈哈哈
Jake: How about you wash the dishes? Hahaha
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:呃OK
Jake: Uh, okay.
Jake:那那你直接这样嘛
Jake: Then you just do it like this.
Jake:你你觉得怎么样
Jake: What do you think?
Jake:贴着贴哎
Jake: Stick it on, hey.
Jake:拿个工具
Jake: Grab a tool.
Jake:呵呵呵挺好
Jake: Hehehe, good.
Jake:没事没事
Jake: It's fine, it's fine.
Jake:问题不大
Jake: No big deal.
Jake:哦那你看怎么贴
Jake: Oh, then you see how to stick it.
Jake:爱爱咋贴咋贴
Jake: Stick it however you like.
Lucia: 飘窗柜好像很有用的鸭子
Lucia: The bay window cabinet seems really useful.
Jake:你弄矮一点
Jake: Make it a bit shorter.
Jake:那贴一个
Jake: Then stick one.
Jake:等一下贴硬盘上 1 2
Jake: Wait, stick it on the hard drive. 1, 2...
Katrina: 天呐好多好看的都是要做手工
Katrina: Oh my god, so many pretty things need to be handmade.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Katrina: 啊直接到浮夸了
Katrina: Ah, it's getting too extravagant.
Jake:教外国人用淘宝也挺好
Jake: Teaching foreigners to use Taobao is also nice.
Jake:让他们羡慕去
Jake: Make them envious.
Lucia: 有哪个购物平台给咱给赞助吗
Lucia: Is there any shopping platform sponsoring us?
Lucia: 就多用用他们的
Lucia: We can use theirs more often.
Jake:这还有个帽子还戴着呢哈
Jake: There's still a hat here, wear it.
Lucia: 啊亚马逊是吗
Lucia: Ah, Amazon, right?
Lucia: 他们已经会用了不用教
Lucia: They already know how to use it, no need to teach.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Katrina: 我要买几个摆在我那
Katrina: I want to buy a few to put at my place.
Jake:这就直接导
Jake: Just import directly.
Jake:自然前面的数据都不太好
Jake: Naturally, the previous data isn't very good.
Jake:呃这个
Jake: Uh, this.
Jake:你们这个硬盘里面贴这个
Jake: Stick this inside the hard drive.
Jake:暗号是第二层
Jake: The code is on the second layer.
Jake:所以对对对
Jake: So, yes, yes, yes.
Jake:专门专门做Pro的第二层
Jake: Specifically for the Pro, it's on the second layer.
Jake:然后你按照每一个相机
Jake: Then you follow each camera.
Jake:呃然后每一天
Jake: Um, and then each day.
Jake:这个
Jake: This.
Jake:指导视频
Jake: Instruction video.
Jake:对指导视频制号MB4
Jake: Yes, the instruction video, number MB4.
Jake:别的都不用
Jake: Nothing else is needed.
Jake:哦哦哦哈哈
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, haha.
Jake:他会切自己会切
Jake: He will cut it himself.
Alice:还满意吗
Alice: Satisfied?
Tasha: 可以呀谢谢
Tasha: Yeah, it's fine, thanks.
Jake:然后这个先上
Jake: Then serve this first.
Jake:先上这个盘对吧
Jake: Serve this dish first, right?
Jake:这个这个盘
Jake: This, this dish.
Jake:好呃呃
Jake: Okay, um, um.
Jake:还没连上
Jake: Not connected yet.
Jake:连上
Jake: Connect it.
Jake:这个
Jake: This.
Jake:后边后边
Jake: The back, the back.
Jake:插上了这边
Jake: Plug it in here.
Jake:如果我原来帮他插上了
Jake: If I originally plugged it in.
Jake:然后你现在没有
Jake: And now you don't have it.
Jake:他要可热化一下
Jake: He needs to heat it up a bit.
Jake:贴的不太对是吧
Jake: It's not sticking right, is it?
Jake:你往下贴贴
Jake: Stick it lower.
Jake:其实就好
Jake: It should be fine.
Jake:啊确定
Jake: Ah, confirm.
Jake:一路确定下去
Jake: Confirm all the way.
Jake:你这没有
Jake: You don't have it.
Jake:那那再拍一次
Jake: Then shoot it again.
Lucia: 抄作业了
Lucia: Copying homework.
Lucia: 哈哈没事
Lucia: Haha, it's fine.
Tasha: 什么都没干
Tasha: Didn't do anything.
Lucia: 你做作业
Lucia: Do your homework.
Lucia: 你放心的做作业
Lucia: Just do your homework without worry.
Jake:好结束了
Jake: Okay, it's done.
Jake:然后放对
Jake: Then place it right.
Jake:一般放个瓶
Jake: Usually place a bottle.
Jake:左边左边右边
Jake: Left, left, right.
Lucia: 啊你剪的这个好漂亮呀
Lucia: Ah, what you cut is so beautiful!
Alice:这都是我捡的
Alice: I picked all these.
Lucia: 啊这也好看
Lucia: Ah, this one looks great too.
Lucia: 这面看特别有层次感
Lucia: This side has a lot of depth.
Lucia: 啊你的这个也还没开
Lucia: Ah, yours hasn't bloomed yet either.
Alice:嗯还没有呢
Alice: Yeah, not yet.
Lucia: 我那个也是
Lucia: Mine too.
Lucia: 都还没开
Lucia: They haven't bloomed yet.
Alice:欣赏一下
Alice: Just admire it.
Jake:好看
Jake: Looks good.
Jake:是修剪了一遍
Jake: It was pruned once.
Alice:yes
Alice: Yes.
Jake:修剪了狠狠的修剪了一遍
Jake: Pruned, really pruned hard.
Alice:也没有还很一般般
Alice: Not really, it's still pretty average.
Jake:确实好看了很多
Jake: It does look much better.
Lucia: 我好奇一下大家都写的什么符号
Lucia: I'm curious, what symbols did everyone draw?
Alice:我给他画的翅膀
Alice: I drew wings for him.
Lucia: 小翅膀
Lucia: Little wings.
Jake:翅膀但是画的有点丑
Jake: Wings, but they look a bit ugly.
Alice:但是画的有点丑
Alice: But they look a bit ugly.
Jake:还没写写一下
Jake: Haven't written yet, write it down.
Alice:我是个星
Alice: I drew a star.
Lucia: 我是个小太阳
Lucia: I drew a little sun.
Lucia: 啊雨轩是直接写的名字
Lucia: Ah, Yuxuan wrote his name directly.
Katrina: 哦香薰
Katrina: Oh, an aromatherapy diffuser.
Katrina: 我想买个小香薰
Katrina: I want to buy a small diffuser.
Lucia: 买一串星星灯
Lucia: Buy a string of fairy lights.
Lucia: 直接给房间上挂一圈就完事了
Lucia: Just hang it around the room, and that's it.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:这是我的
Jake: This is mine.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Okay.
Choiszt: 那这导的过程中就完全没用
Choiszt: So it was completely useless during the process.
Lucia: 他是什么花
Lucia: What kind of flower is it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哇很直接了当
Lucia: Wow, that's very straightforward.
Jake:就是只要NB4 其他的都不用
Jake: You only need NB4, nothing else is necessary.
Jake:不用啊哎
Jake: Not necessary, hey.
Jake:人呢他会吗
Jake: Can he do it?
Jake:尼玛哈哈哈你咋跑了
Jake: Damn it, why did you run away?
Choiszt: 我回来了
Choiszt: I'm back.
Jake:哈哈哈你结束
Jake: Hahaha, you finished?
Choiszt: 结束尼玛不让你
Choiszt: Finished your ass, no way.
Jake:哈哈哈 15十五号
Jake: Hahaha, the 15th, fifteen.
Jake:十六号秒
Jake: The 16th, second.
Jake:哎其实没毛病
Jake: Actually, it's not a problem.
Choiszt: 哈哈哈多少慢了点
Choiszt: Hahaha, it's just a bit slow.
Jake:只是慢了
Jake: It's just slow.
Jake:有读卡器可以买读卡器
Jake: If you have a card reader, you can buy a card reader.
Shure: 这里有吧这里有
Shure: There's one here, right?
Jake:就一个硬盘啊
Jake: Just one hard drive?
Jake:但是你速度我不知道
Jake: But your speed, I don't know.
Jake:你两个一起倒速度会有变化吗
Jake: Will the speed change if you copy both at the same time?
Jake:呃应该就是很讲究的命名方式
Jake: Uh, it should be a very particular naming method.
Shure: 这个面糊会不会堵下水道呢
Shure: Won't this batter clog the drain?
Jake:是你呃你现在怎么命名呢
Jake: How do you name it now?
Jake:你现在就直接拖进去是吧
Jake: You just drag it in, right?
Jake:对对对我操
Jake: Yeah, yeah, what the heck.
Jake:你他妈太粗暴了
Jake: You're so rough with it.
Jake:对对对太太太粗暴了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, way too rough.
Jake:来来来这个法2好吧
Jake: Here, try method 2, okay?
Jake:呃那个你是几号相机
Jake: Uh, which camera number are you using?
Jake:那你写个一一一新建文件加一
Jake: Then create a new file and add a 1 to it.
Jake:呃然后进去
Jake: Uh, then go in.
Jake:进去新建一个202404
Jake: Create a new file named 202404.
Jake:从15开始的其实对151617
Jake: Start from 15, right, 15, 16, 17.
Jake:你直接建吧
Jake: Just create it directly.
Jake:然后
Jake: Then...
Jake:到时候你看他创建日期是什么时候
Jake: Check the creation date later.
Jake:你就往里面涂
Jake: And put it in there.
Jake:每一个视频
Jake: Every video...
Jake:他有自己的充电日期
Jake: Has its own charge date.
Jake:啊对这这够快了
Jake: Yeah, this is fast enough.
Jake:比迈克快多了
Jake: Much faster than Mike.
Jake:哎迈克也很快
Jake: Well, Mike is fast too.
Jake:你可以你可以建很多
Jake: You can create many.
Jake:你可以建到22
Jake: You can create up to 22.
Jake:然后这个里面再写相机的那个
Jake: Then write the camera's...
Jake:相机的编号
Jake: Camera number in there.
Jake:对你编号在啊
Jake: Yeah, you have the number, right?
Jake:哎你是二人吗
Jake: Hey, are you from room 22?
Jake:22楼吗没有没有没有你
Jake: 22nd floor? No, no, no, not you.
Jake:你在我最外层
Jake: You're on my outermost layer.
Jake:就这个你要你要
Jake: Just this, you want it?
Jake:拖到一个
Jake: Drag it to one place.
Jake:再到20号
Jake: Then to number 20.
Jake:见到17也行
Jake: Seeing number 17 works too.
Jake:见到17吧
Jake: See number 17.
Jake:然后我就把
Jake: Then I will...
Jake:对你看到日期
Jake: Yeah, you saw the date?
Jake:你看日期了吗
Jake: Did you see the date?
Jake:9号相机
Jake: Camera number 9.
Jake:你的一号相机
Jake: Your camera number 1.
Jake:你的壳还在吧
Jake: Your shell is still there, right?
Jake:他从9号相机开始
Jake: He started from camera number 9.
Shure: 搞定
Shure: Done.
Shure: 全倍亮跟你讲
Shure: All lights on, I'm telling you.
Jake:不用不用
Jake: No need, no need.
Jake:对啊我我觉得不应该这么办了
Jake: Yeah, I think we shouldn't do it this way.
Jake:气死我了
Jake: It's driving me crazy.
Jake:1234
Jake: 1, 2, 3, 4.
Jake:我原来想一个小时在这转一圈搞定
Jake: I originally thought I could finish this in an hour.
Jake:他妈头崩了
Jake: Damn, my head is exploding.
Shure: 啊搞定
Shure: Ah, done.
Jake:是我原来还没有买这种卡
Jake: I originally didn't buy this type of card.
Jake:所以说我得插到GoPro
Jake: So I need to insert it into the GoPro.
Jake:就是把那个充电线给插电脑上
Jake: Just plug the charging cable into the computer.
Jake:然后开始倒
Jake: Then start transferring.
Jake:然后每一个一个一个跑
Jake: And run each one by one.
Jake:就是原来的方案是推着这个小桌子
Jake: The original plan was to push this small table around.
Jake:然后推着到处跑
Jake: And run around pushing it.
Jake:然后碰到傻逼了
Jake: Then I ran into idiots.
Jake:哈哈哈太难了
Jake: Hahaha, it's too hard.
Shure: 在点什么
Shure: What are you clicking on?
Jake:太慢了又慢又麻烦
Jake: It's too slow, both slow and troublesome.
Choiszt: they are就两两个人
Choiszt: They are just two people.
Choiszt: 好歹一人一层啊
Choiszt: At least one per floor.
Choiszt: 我他妈一人15个
Choiszt: I'm handling 15 alone.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 我要不要去搬俩凳子下来
Lucia: Should I go get two chairs down?
Shure: 我一会在上面吃还是下面吃火锅
Shure: Should I eat hotpot upstairs or downstairs later?
Jake:我在下面吃
Jake: I'll eat downstairs.
Lucia: 啊啥
Lucia: Huh, what?
Lucia: 我们是在上面还是下面
Lucia: Are we eating upstairs or downstairs?
Katrina: 现在在shoping
Katrina: We're shopping now.
Lucia: 如果在下面的话我就再搬俩凳子下来
Lucia: If we're eating downstairs, I'll bring down a couple of chairs.
Jake:小品
Jake: "Xiaopin"
Katrina: shoping中
Katrina: Shopping.
Jake:好好在下面吃
Jake: Okay, we'll eat downstairs.
Lucia: 那行
Lucia: Alright then.
Jake:呃我想一下在下面时
Jake: Hmm, let me think about it downstairs.
Jake:可以在下面去
Jake: We can go downstairs.
Jake:你出来被拍吧
Jake: You come out and be filmed.
Jake:你就给点
Jake: Just give us some footage.
Jake:你给点素材出来拍
Jake: Give us some material to shoot.
Jake:给你你的座位嘛座位
Jake: Here's your seat, your seat.
Shure: 席地而坐
Shure: Sitting on the floor.
Shure: 大象席地而坐
Shure: Like an elephant sitting on the floor.
Jake:一个吉他
Jake: A guitar.
Jake:还是被扫过的
Jake: It's been strummed.
Jake:这是一个赛博系统
Jake: This is a cyber system.
Shure: 是吗啊
Shure: Really?
Shure: 他有自己的生命了
Shure: It has its own life now.
Jake:对但是他不是赛博的
Jake: Yes, but it's not cyber.
Jake:你是赛博的
Jake: You are cyber.
Shure: 那也就是现在
Shure: So now...
Jake:呵呵哈哈哈哈哈哈啊
Jake: Haha, hahaha.
Shure: 就是凭空就有一个人
Shure: Like a person just appeared out of nowhere.
Shure: 有一把吉他在这里自己发声是吗
Shure: And there's a guitar here making sounds by itself, right?
Jake:谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you.
Lucia: 我们差差31234567然后我们有几个人
Lucia: We have a difference of 31234567 and then how many people do we have?
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 八个人再拿一个
Lucia: Eight people, get one more.
Jake:酒来酒
Jake: Bring the wine, wine.
Jake:I99号卡
Jake: I99 card.
Jake:刚刚是谁拿走的
Jake: Who just took it?
Jake:9号 海
Jake: Number 9, Hai.
Shure: 9号在我这里
Shure: Number 9 is with me.
Choiszt: 现在导着9号
Choiszt: Now directing number 9.
Jake:有人挑
Jake: Someone chose.
Shure: 有人挑啊有人挑有人第一次一首都没挑
Shure: Some people are picky, some people are picky, and some people didn't pick a single song on their first try.
Jake:树确实爽多了啊
Jake: The trees definitely make it more enjoyable.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright.
Shure: 对加入到歌单
Shure: Yes, add it to the playlist.
Shure: 然后放入到易狗里面
Shure: And then put it in the app.
Shure: 就是你说那更多那块
Shure: It's like you said, that extra part.
Shure: 然后收藏
Shure: And then save it.
Shure: 然后到一狗里面
Shure: And then put it in the app.
Shure: 想想我们要干什么家人们
Shure: Think about what we're gonna do, guys.
Jake:找一个任务修硕
Jake: Find a task, Shure.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:看一下我做这个然后让以后添加一下你发下内个
Jake: Look at me doing this, then add it later and send it over.
Shure: 行不行我加完了我要从新点击然后点击啊
Shure: Is it okay? Once I add it, I have to click again and then click.
Choiszt: 没有并没有我看你各留
Choiszt: No, not at all, I've been watching you.
Shure: 你们会翻绳吗会翻绳吗会翻绳翻绳
Shure: Do you guys know how to do rope tricks? Rope tricks? Rope tricks?
Choiszt: 会什么
Choiszt: Know how to do what?
Shure: 拿绳来那内个充电器
Shure: Bring a rope, that charger.
Shure: 咱们不至于这么赛博吧
Shure: We can't be this cyber, can we?
Shure: 有没有棉线什么的
Shure: Do we have any cotton string or something?
Choiszt: 没有没有
Choiszt: No, no.
Jake:以房间装扮吗
Jake: Are we decorating the room?
Shure: 啊你房间装扮吗
Shure: Oh, are you decorating the room?
Jake:房间装扮吗
Jake: Decorating the room?
Shure: 我的房间好像没有什么太装扮的东西
Shure: I don't think my room has much to decorate with.
Jake:多少啊
Jake: How much?
Tasha: 找你最难免的是理由是我要说什么
Tasha: The hardest thing to find is a reason for what I want to say.
Tasha: 可以不说
Tasha: You don't have to say it.
Tasha: 20
Tasha: 20.
Jake:要不学学他一会
Jake: Why not learn from him for a while?
Shure: 这个角落真的好好看
Shure: This corner looks really nice.
Jake:太难了
Jake: It's too hard.
Jake:对回
Jake: Yeah, go back.
Jake:头删了已经
Jake: It's already deleted.
Jake:倒完才删
Jake: Deleted it after finishing.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:怎么这么说
Jake: Why do you say that?
Jake:就是这个
Jake: It's just this.
Jake:go Pro晚上到几点
Jake: How late does the GoPro go at night?
Jake:在一晚上了
Jake: All night.
Jake:等一等让我睡个觉
Jake: Wait a sec, let me take a nap.
Jake:多一个人能让我多睡好几个小时
Jake: Having one more person can let me sleep a few more hours.
Jake:给我戴个眼镜
Jake: Give me some glasses.
Jake:什么眼睛
Jake: What kind of glasses?
Jake:这个眼睛
Jake: These glasses.
Jake:没问题
Jake: No problem.
Jake:那你有热吧
Jake: Are you hot?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 我们昨天看见他的衣服了
Shure: We saw his clothes yesterday.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 那我们去扒他衣服去
Shure: Let's go strip his clothes.
Shure: 扒他裤子
Shure: Strip his pants.
Jake:对已经关了
Jake: Yeah, it's already off.
Jake:没电了应该
Jake: It should be out of battery.
Jake:可能没电了
Jake: It might be out of battery.
Jake:sorry今天还在
Jake: Sorry, it's still on today.
Shure: 应该是没电了
Shure: It should be out of battery.
Jake:插充电宝
Jake: Plug in the power bank.
Shure: 那有一打刚才
Shure: There was a dozen earlier.
Jake:算再录录了再没人再看一下时间
Jake: Let's record again and if no one watches, check the time again.
Jake:救命哈哈
Jake: Help, haha.
Jake:计时计时
Jake: Time it, time it.
Jake:对对对然后每人都要看
Jake: Yeah, yeah, then everyone needs to watch.
Jake:每人都要看
Jake: Everyone needs to watch.
Jake:啊不不不
Jake: Ah, no, no, no.
Jake:一个秒表
Jake: A stopwatch.
Jake:一个精确到后几位的秒表
Jake: A stopwatch that counts to the last few digits.
Jake:这个不中
Jake: This one won't do.
Jake:是不是今天下午命名
Jake: Is it named this afternoon?
Jake:上面规定具体时间不重要
Jake: The specific time set above is not important.
Jake:时间线比较重要
Jake: The timeline is more important.
Jake:就是不要那么具体
Jake: Just don't be so specific.
Jake:差个5分钟没关系
Jake: It's okay to be off by 5 minutes.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 室内设计
Shure: Interior design.
Jake:先插电了
Jake: Plug it in first.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:插电了有电吗
Jake: Did you plug it in? Is there power?
Jake:没电而这上有电呢
Jake: No power, but there's power on this side.
Jake:互相有电
Jake: There's mutual power.
Shure: 而且我充的时候等一下我再给你冲一下
Shure: Also, when I charge it, wait a second and I'll charge it for you again.
Lucia: 上一段内个哎呦
Lucia: The last part, oh no.
Jake:哎呦呦没电了话
Jake: Oh no, it's out of battery.
Katrina: 嗯在在在
Katrina: Yeah, it's here.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 没有纸什么的
Lucia: There's no paper or anything.
Shure: 这歌单成分太复杂了只能说
Shure: This playlist is too complex, I can only say.
Lucia: 这这个也没倒是吗
Lucia: This, this one hasn't been poured, right?
Jake:对这个没倒
Jake: Yeah, this one hasn't been poured.
Alice:是卫生纸
Alice: It's toilet paper.
Lucia: 哎饿两个小时再坐
Lucia: Oh, wait for two hours and then sit.
Jake:你命个名
Jake: You name it.
Jake:然后大家跟你对个齐
Jake: And then everyone will align with you.
Jake:对齐时间
Jake: Align the time.
Lucia: 这这个纸是可以用的吗
Lucia: Can this paper be used?
Jake:然后又可以去玩
Jake: And then we can go play.
Lucia: 算了万一我就随便写一下
Lucia: Forget it, I'll just write something randomly.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 就稍微记录一下灵感
Lucia: Just jot down some inspiration.
Choiszt: 可以打扰一下拿一下这个A4纸A4纸
Choiszt: Can I bother you to get some A4 paper, A4 paper?
Katrina: 你看他不给开
Katrina: Look, he won't turn it on.
Jake:因为太因为没电是吧
Jake: Because it's out of battery, right?
Katrina: 他这个详细给的太多了
Katrina: He gave too many details.
Jake:现在多low啊
Jake: It's so low now.
Jake:太low啊
Jake: So low.
Jake:10% 坐一会吧
Jake: 10%, let's sit for a bit.
Katrina: 换鞋我要去看一下小狗
Katrina: Change shoes, I need to go check on the puppy.
Shure: 今天太忙了
Shure: It's so busy today.
Choiszt: 啊
Choiszt: Ah.
Katrina: 哥等我等我去看一下小狗我们在画这个
Katrina: Bro, wait, wait, I'll go check on the puppy, we're drawing this.
Jake:嘿你这个挺好
Jake: Hey, this is pretty good.
Jake:掌握了精髓
Jake: You've got the essence.
Jake:在画画我在想主要的话
Jake: Drawing, I'm thinking mainly about...
Lucia: 不我在想
Lucia: No, I'm thinking.
Lucia: 我怎样能把那个他
Lucia: How can I make this room.
Lucia: 这个房间设计的更好看一点
Lucia: Look better.
Jake:我去你这个是啥呀
Jake: Wow, what is this?
Alice:花
Alice: A flower.
Jake:这什么材料呢
Jake: What material is this?
Lucia: 如果是1.5乘
Lucia: If it's 1.5 times
Alice:卫生纸
Alice: Toilet paper
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my god
Lucia: 哇好好看
Lucia: Wow, it looks so good
Lucia: 你已经又上了一层颜色
Lucia: You've added another layer of color
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:确实挺牛逼
Jake: It's really impressive
Lucia: 这是1*2米
Lucia: This is 1*2 meters
Jake:不给我看是不
Jake: Are you not going to show me?
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why?
Alice:你在干什么
Alice: What are you doing?
Katrina: 我在画我在设计
Katrina: I'm drawing, I'm designing
Lucia: 没有我正在想
Lucia: No, I'm just thinking
Lucia: 我那个做成什么样的比例比较好
Lucia: About what proportion would be best
Lucia: 我打算拿一个渔网把它挂一下
Lucia: I plan to hang it with a fishing net
Katrina: 哦我也想这样
Katrina: Oh, I want to do that too
Katrina: 画减笔
Katrina: Less lines
Alice:应该拿个便宜点的颜色
Alice: We should use cheaper colors
Alice:有点心疼
Alice: It's a bit painful
Tasha: 啊哈
Tasha: Aha
Alice:对没有别的干枯玫瑰
Alice: Yeah, no other dried roses
Jake:哈哈哈 6台眼镜的人
Jake: Hahaha, six pairs of glasses
Jake:对啊他们可不敢
Jake: Yeah, they wouldn't dare
Alice:用点不常用的颜色
Alice: Use some uncommon colors
Tasha: 嗯哼 哼
Tasha: Mmm-hmm
Alice:要不然我心疼
Alice: Or else I'll feel bad
Tasha: 还好不常用
Tasha: It's okay, not often used
Alice:还可以吧
Alice: It's okay
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha: 啊哈
Tasha: Aha
Jake:我以为你们都不用
Jake: I thought you guys didn't use it
Jake:有了有了
Jake: Got it, got it
Jake:有了可以用
Jake: Got it, we can use it
Jake:当然可以用
Jake: Of course, we can use it
Jake:主要是位置不太大
Jake: The main issue is the space isn't big
Jake:这触摸板确实不太灵敏
Jake: This touchpad is really not very sensitive
Jake:我不知道苹果
Jake: I don't know about Apple
Jake:他不一定有苹果
Jake: He might not have Apple
Jake:你的苹果没有那个
Jake: Your Apple doesn't have that
Jake:那那个口
Jake: That port
Jake:没有SD口
Jake: There's no SD port.
Tasha: 你脚乱蹬
Tasha: Your feet are all over the place.
Lucia: 哇完美融入
Lucia: Wow, perfect integration.
Jake:其实也可以
Jake: Actually, it works too.
Jake:共15台你三三三一人5台也行
Jake: We have 15 units, three per person, five each is fine.
Lucia: 啊真的好完美融入
Lucia: Ah, it really blends in perfectly.
Lucia: 可以看一下吗
Lucia: Can I take a look?
Lucia: 啊不算
Lucia: Ah, never mind.
Lucia: 你已经插进去了
Lucia: You've already inserted it.
Alice:无所谓拿着看吧
Alice: Doesn't matter, take a look.
Lucia: 哈哈我害怕把它碰
Lucia: Haha, I'm afraid I'll touch it.
Lucia: 会不会就是啊
Lucia: Will it, ah...
Lucia: 哇真的很完美融入
Lucia: Wow, it really blends in perfectly.
Lucia: 好看好看
Lucia: Looks good, looks good.
Jake:还有一个这个这个这个研究者就是
Jake: And there's this researcher, um...
Jake:再来一个硬盘呗
Jake: Let's get another hard drive.
Jake:Wu能快一点吧
Jake: Wu, can you speed up?
Jake:也不一定
Jake: Not necessarily.
Jake:不不不就就就三台硬盘
Jake: No, no, no, just three hard drives.
Jake:就这样吧就这样吧
Jake: That's it, that's it.
Jake:确实确实
Jake: Indeed, indeed.
Jake:多歇一会也行
Jake: You can rest a bit longer.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake:保安都删了
Jake: The security deleted it.
Jake:保安你看一眼视频差不多对不对
Jake: Security, take a look at the video, it's about right, isn't it?
Jake:一般我们看这个就是大小对不对
Jake: Usually, we check the size, right?
Jake:对了就没问题
Jake: If it's correct, there's no problem.
Jake:就是分屏
Jake: It's just split screens.
Jake:一般我你看都全是分屏
Jake: Usually, you see, it's all split screens.
Jake:12个头对 12个屏
Jake: 12 heads, right, 12 screens.
Choiszt: 对其他的单独的算
Choiszt: Yes, the rest are counted separately.
Jake:好然后再装回去
Jake: Okay, then put it back.
Jake:装回到这个里边
Jake: Put it back in here.
Jake:你们有几个人一起一场
Jake: How many of you are doing this together?
Jake:那个魔力大变
Jake: That magic transformation.
Jake:今天早上10个
Jake: There were 10 this morning.
Shure: 10个好像将近10个
Shure: Yeah, about 10.
Jake:你第几个
Jake: Which one are you?
Shure: 我第
Shure: I'm the...
Shure: 不是谁谁自告奋勇
Shure: Not sure, who volunteered?
Shure: 就是谁先来
Shure: So, who goes first?
Jake:你是好奋友
Jake: You're a good friend.
Shure: 我第二个
Shure: I'll go second.
Shure: 我第一个
Shure: No, I'll go first.
Shure: 没没没答上
Shure: No, no, I didn't answer.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 然后我后面的同学
Shure: Then my classmate behind me...
Shure: 呃就是我女朋友
Shure: Uh, she's my girlfriend.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 她电脑突然放不出来了
Shure: Her computer suddenly stopped working.
Shure: 然后又借她电脑用一下
Shure: So I borrowed her computer for a bit.
Jake:哦你要帮帮那个忙
Jake: Oh, you need to help with that?
Shure: 然后所以就10点半正好答完
Shure: So, I finished answering at exactly 10:30.
Jake:所以最后他们10个人的话结束
Jake: So, they finished with all 10 people in the end?
Jake:没有结束
Jake: Didn't finish?
Shure: 12点多
Shure: Around 12 o'clock.
Shure: 9点到12点
Shure: From 9 to 12.
Jake:路上就是有一些我
Jake: On the way, I...
Jake:我用就是我手忙脚乱的导出来了
Jake: I used it, and I clumsily extracted it.
Jake:在那个硬盘里
Jake: It's on the hard drive.
Jake:我把硬盘给你们
Jake: I'll give you the hard drive.
Jake:然后还是把硬盘给青春
Jake: Or I'll give the hard drive to Youth.
Jake:你你你你先整别的吧
Jake: You, you, you handle something else first.
Jake:USB卡比较隔热就完事了
Jake: The USB card is more heat-resistant, that's all.
Jake:你可以给他隔热化
Jake: You can make it heat-resistant.
Jake:运营也行
Jake: It can also work for operations.
Jake:金猪帮我
Jake: Gold Pig, help me out.
Jake:把我的水给我
Jake: Pass me my water.
Jake:帮忙收点数据吧
Jake: Help gather some data.
Shure: 什么数据
Shure: What data?
Jake:多多多看看昨天买的东西
Jake: Take a look at what we bought yesterday.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Jake:一些毫无逻辑的行为
Jake: Some completely illogical actions.
Jake:硬加一些QA
Jake: Just add some QA.
Jake:好吧你你就出题
Jake: Okay, you just come up with the questions.
Jake:好吧你现在就哈哈哈
Jake: Alright, just go ahead and do it, haha.
Shure: 为什么我们要买这些东西
Shure: Why did we buy these things?
Shure: 白糖是干什么的
Shure: What's the sugar for?
Shure: 玉米淀粉又是干什么
Shure: What about the corn starch?